[Music]
every kid has that one gift they want
more than anything for christmas
this is the story of mine
bookends and they have baseballs on them
i see that no not those nintendo
a maze of rubber wiring and electronic
intelligence so advanced it was deemed
not a video game but an 8-bit
entertainment
no nintendo in my house i second that
looks like a no-go on nintendo
i needed a christmas miracle
the year was 1987 or was it 88 super
bowls okay does it really matter dad oh
okay the year was the late 80s i was 11
years old did you wear a helmet yeah we
always wore helmets in the 80s
[Music]
me and my friends would do anything just
to play one any of you huddled masters
wanna play
what have you brought me
untraceable cash money it's the final
downtown
one thing became clear i needed to get
my own
this is bigger than christmas
[Music]
this is our vietnam i don't think that
means what you think it means i have no
idea what it means we're gonna get in so
much trouble
sometimes during christmas just when you
think that all hope is lost something
magical happens
[Music]
sold out in 20 minutes sadly one woman
punched a grandma right in the throat
same family too
are you making all this up no no no way
you guys here in the race selling
contests first prize is a brand new
nintendo entertainment system
i'm gonna kill you hold on
[Music]
there are no rules
that nintendo's mine
what do you want to buy a
this kid thinks your wreath sucks
video games
have been doing all kinds of strange
things to children
what it was the 80s stuff got real
red dog this is bluebird this is rainbow
one what happened to red dog i changed
it well let's change names now this is
millennium falcon super cool
love it rated pg
[Music]
you